so we have some updates on Daredevil uh
for Disney plus uh the first is it's
going to be longer than the Marvel
related series have been for the most
part it's going to be run 18 episodes
which is quite a bit longer than these
usually have we are also now having the
return of John barenthal as The Punisher
which uh personally I'm a little mixed
on he was pretty good in season two of
Daredevil he was one of the better parts
of that season
um but I didn't super love uh how his
Punisher was handled I got bored with
the series but he did work well off of
Charlie Cox so that could still be good
unfortunately neither the character of
foggy Nelson nor Karen Page are going to
be returning and it'll be interesting to
see how the Punisher fits in given that
born again the story that the series is
taking his name from doesn't feature him
but it's not uncommon for the Marvel
stuff to take a title and do something
different with it the lingering question
for me right now is whether or not a
lecture is going to feature and if so
are they going to recast
we'll see